our next presenter one in a double ACP
image award for bail she made her
writing debut on the secret laughter of
women and adapted Zora Neale Hurston's
their eyes were watching god presenting
the award to Spencer Harvey and Lloyd
Harvey is Miss ansa guy
good evening bringing diverse voices
into filmmaking is often portrayed as
hard work but diversity is nature's norm
an effort has to be made to achieve the
unit uniformity that we're used to it
takes effort to close your eyes and ears
to people who don't look like you love
like you or people who you may not meet
in your normal life what has thrilled me
about the deliberations in the Nichols
committee is witnessing what happens
when you look for excellence in a pool
that hasn't been pre-sorted like that
eyes minds and hearts been open and it's
created a strong field of excellent
script diversity of voice not as a chore
but as the tremendous privilege that it
is and that process has brought me to
photo booth written by Spencer Harvey
and Lloyd Harvey a soulful brother and
sister team writing from Australia I
asked who they were not twins but they
write together they direct together and
they also run a video business together
a grown up brother and sister who really
get on if that isn't diversity I don't
know what is I asked how do they achieve
that single voice they work in a room
together draft after draft but most of
all I asked why this story and they said
because the themes of family of
parenting were important to them they
felt compelled to write this story they
called it therapy by opening up the tent
to new voices like Spencer in Lloyd we
hear different stories and our lives are
enriched with as we're transported to
places we would never normally go or
exposed to different points of view but
there
another pleasure you might not have
considered if you're from the majority
audience whose stories have always been
told that bliss of at last hearing a
voice that echoes yours glorious moment
when you recognize self I had such a
moment when i read photo booth it's a
complex script and at first I wasn't
sure what I was reading was it a family
drama was it the story of a marriage
falling apart was it a morality tale
about the consequences of infidelity
were we going to see a bunny boiling at
some stage but why did it grabbed me and
why wouldn't it let me go it took me a
while to understand that what was
speaking to me was that was the
characters Spencer and Lloyd had created
complex women at all stages of
motherhood brought them to life in a
tour de force of storytelling motherhood
in this unexpected script is not the
saintliness the goodness and the
selflessness we associate with that word
but the grab enos the greed of
motherhood the messiness the mistakes
the have a go element with this greatest
leap of faith we make it's all here
painful truthful the grand moments and
the squalid bargained and they were
brave enough not to have nice characters
because not only nice people deserve our
sympathy it's a stunning piece of
writing and it spoke so loudly to me I
fully expected it to be written by a
woman of a certain age like me how wrong
was I so we opened the tent wide because
we can never know in advance who will
give us that moment of bliss your script
did that for me Spencer in Lloyd thank
you for writing it
thank you a little blown away I'm sorry
thank you Miss on thank you so much for
those beautiful words and um and I want
to extend it thank you too to Fe and
Rodrigo and these incredible actors here
tonight but for bringing our humble
words to life so thank you very much we
feel ill-equipped just to stand on the
stage and speak after you but um my
sister and I will try sir and we're used
to sharing because our parents told us
so and so we're going to share a suite
yes yeah yeah to us this screenplay
started out as a seed of an idea seed of
an idea and it has only been allowed to
grow because of the care of others our
parents our first loves who taught us
that ideas are worth planting our
partners Louisa and Garth who tended to
it reading every draft often out loud
and with as much feeling and further as
the first time our writers group in
sydney's some of whom are here who
ordered our seed in 10 page installments
encouraging it and asked to grow and as
it grew it absorbed these caretakers
into itself into its roots its trunk to
our friends Harry every meatus
Bennigan's and Ben Smith who became its
first branches urging it to reach beyond
our backyard to amanda hinson who three
years ago believed in our seed before it
had sprouted and today with our agents
Blair Cohen and David Flynn her field uh
tree with bright green leaves bright
green leaves that embellish our trees
first flower and that flower is the
Academy Nicole fellowship so to us each
petal of that flower is a reader a judge
and each and every member of this team
committee there is there the pedal for
Greg and Joan and for the whole nickel
team who
truly believe in what they do and the
little seeds that we and our incredible
fellow finalists and fellows bring to
their garden a garden which we are
grateful to be in forever planted for us
this fellowship is truly as a gift give
which this thank you note seems far too
small we will cherish this moment we
will cherish this evening and for us for
allowing Australians into the house
thank you thank you